bonjour et bienvenue sur des gones ltv
pour la suite de ce championnat du monde
2016 entre donc le tenant du titre
magnus carsen au norvégien et le russe
sergueï kaliakine son challenger donc on
a maintenant passé neuf partis c'est la
10ème et c'est khanaqinne voilà on voit
dans le classement ici dans le score de
ce match c'est qu'à la quine qui a créé
la grosse surprise en gagnant la
huitième partie a pris 7 nuls qui laisse
car scène au pied du mur quatre parties
pour revenir il a déjà souffert un en
plus dans la neuvième on sent qu'il est
fatigué et on est donc à la 10e partie
il n'y a plus que deux fois les blancs
pour tenter de revenir au score et
espérer conserver son titre faudra
encore soit en gagner deux soi mais sur
gagner au départage
donc il est en difficulté car scène mais
il a les blancs c'est une partie très
importante
on est donc ici sur sur sept sur sept
dixièmes partie car c'est mon cas les
blancs c'est là sans doute la dernière
occasion pour lui d'essayer de revenir
au score
il est un peu voilà mis dans les dix
positions inconfortables un peu comme
kasparov en 87 qui devait remporter
absolument les lanières partie face à
face à karpov au match fameux match de
séville
là c'est le fameux match de new york
entre donc car ce n est qu harry aikines
c'est parti avec eux quatre alors est-ce
qu'on va encore avoir droit
un des bus espagnol e5 kf3 qu'elle
laissait 6 alors le coup dur oui lopez
sans doute encore une fois et oui faut
b5 c'est c'est le début oui lopez c'est
une rue l'open mais c'est ça va pas être
sans doute la grande espagnol puisque
cas rien qui n'a joué dans les parties
précédentes la défense de berlin on va
voir est-ce qu'il renouvelle donc
défense de berlin c'est le cavalier m6
et la grande partie espagnole
qui suit la grande grandes variantes
c'est à 6 et on avait les deux joueurs
qui choisissent une défense différente
avec les noirs c'est un match l'espagnol
ce match et bien voilà câble et f6
qu'elle épaississe donc encore à défense
de berlin donc c'est du déjà vu et la d3
parle des trois quarts c'est nord c'est
le traitement à la carcel on rentre pas
dans les grandes variantes que sport va
essayer de réfuter ce début en prenant
le cavalier ses 6 puis en prenant 1.5 c
- le style de carsen d'essayer de forcer
le gagnant le début il préfère obtenir
une position complexe tout simplement
avec un léger avantage
essayez de 2 pouces et ça dans des
parties longues techniques poussées
scène qui pour les noirs ces trois voilà
les blancs prépare deux choses ici
impose potentiellement des quatre plus
tard et aussi x 4 pouces et 2 une foule
b3 ou éventuellement pousser deux on
peut faire ça aussi
voilà donc ces trois en tout cas ils
veulent pas développer leurs cavaliers
sur ces 3 alors soit on a trois dans
certains cas mais surtout des deux fn
chez trois ans 8,3 des choses comme ça
on a déjà vu ce type de manoeuvre petit
rock foo g5 ont tous cavaliers ce qui
rend la poussée des seins que délicate
il par exemple sur des scènes tout de
suite aux répressions prend d'un brin
forcé puisque le cavalier ne peut pas à
cause du fou qui attaqueraient adam
comprenait la dame et lorsqu'à la foudre
en cavalier et le rock et est cassé et
de reprendre du pian on a cassé le rock
et demi ce qui est une bonne affaire
cache six ans très bien france 4 et les
blancs disent au noir ben vas-y pouces
g5
parce que si on pousse les pions devant
le roi peut-être les blancs frollo grand
roque et ils vont balancer une attaque
de pion entre contre le roc voilà donc
qu'ils aient dit il incite les noirs à
s'affaiblir là il tombe pas dans le
piège voilà car yakine ils reviennent
tout simplement en 7 et donc pas de
problème
maintenant on peut même envisager des
scènes puisque en cas de prise du
cavalier on peut prendre mais sur des
cinq prises si on peut prendre la dame
aussi je me disais si avait pas cavalier
prend ses six meilleurs français si ce
n'est pas pas tout de suite
petit rock c'est pas rien de n'être ici
des six ans l'un très bien qu'à elle et
des deux
tout ça est très classique des
développements de pièces classiques dans
ce type d'ouverture rue lopez la défense
de berlin câble et h5 alors c'est
amusant parce que là c'est une partie
précédente on avait vu dans ce type de
d'ouverture alors c'est pas la même
ouverture en restait pas mais encore une
fois le cavalier qui vient h5 aulas ici
ça permet ça évidemment ça invite à un
échange de fou et vice aussi la cazelle
4 on avait déjà signalé une possibilité
comme ça dans une partie avec arsène
avec les noirs drire la dernière il
faudra en fout d'apprendre très bien pas
de problème pour l'instant qu'à blesser
4 à l'intention petit menacent s'ils
n'en font pas attention
kalif 3.5 mais oui parce que carey price
trois parcelles on peut pas prendre de
la dame
parce que prendre la dame protégerait le
cavalier f5 donc comme les trois points
c'est qu'on soit en prendre qu à bissau
du pion et derrière pouf
c'est le carré la chaîne qui
emprisonnera gagner un pion au passage
donc attention à ça qu'elle lève 4 voilà
donc le cavaly vient sur une case active
avec catherine est superbe
ainsi si on le repousse ils pourront
peut venir faire un essai à astro un
échec ou voir en revenir en j'ai si
souvent le 6 mai certainement pas h5 à
cause de voilà de cette attaque de la
nabe câble est très actif c'est très
très bien dans le passé de la part des
noirs ici
car la chine joue très bien pour
l'instant ce début carlier 3
les blancs voilà maintenant replace
leurs cavaliers ils visent la casse des
cinq la case f 5 ou 6 peut-être trail
est très bien placé en 3 mai donc il ya
plus fous de cases noires ils viennent
pas ils viennent pas et il est il bien
placé dames et dames f6 aussi en partie
précédente on avait cette possibilité là
de placement la dame f6 clavier f4 voyez
donc noté ça c'est intéressant qu'à
lille à damiers se replacer donc si on
attaque la dame plus tard peut-être
laden viendront g6 du coup ce genre de
choses je ne sais pas elle préférait
peut-être il veut aussi replacer son
cavalier recettes et g6 pour doubler il
double les cavaliers comme ça pourquoi
pas possible l'ibère la case de cette
aussi g3 donc les blancs laisse pas
traîner là ce cavalier comme un peu
pénible dans le camp dans lequel ils le
chassent tout de suite à l' échec
on croit cheveux problèmes dont ils
préfèrent venir à achat parce que quand
ce cavalier va bouger plus tard jour ou
l'autre ce fou pour revenir h3 avec un
échec où la dame aussi bon on préfère le
mettre en action tout de suite dit bon
ference cavaliers ça m'est égal
peut-être il veut juste cavaliers aussi
pour l'apa pour les blancs par engin
tout simplement pas tout de suite parce
qu'il y aura le prix au m2 qui sera
attaquée
il faut calculer quoi ça n'a pas l'air
bon donc avg 1 et plus tard après avoir
joué dans me2 et ensuite peut-être f4
avec un vis-à-vis tour nam possible
aussi voilà car les ossètes voilà l'idée
une des idées du ku'damm et 2006 on a
libéré la cac 2,7 pour le cavalier ce
cas les bains ils rêvent de venir angers
6 sans doute ou même de protéger d'aidé
à la poussée ces six décès un quai voilà
on met la pression sur le centre c'est
possible aussi il faut voir si c'est si
c'est intéressant aussi parce qu'on n'a
pas encore sorti vos pièces côté noir
il nous reste 1 pouces et 8 qui
attendent de trouver sa place a faim de
loup de lier les tours alors que les
blancs quasiment déjà lié leur tour font
bouger la dame encore trouvé une bonne
case parade a poussé quatre donc les
blancs anticipe ses six plutôt que il
met tout de suite leur fou sur ces
diagonales c6 soir là quand même
c'est une idée si on enlève le cavalier
voilà c'est aussi pour jouer c'est 6 de
manière à contrôler homme un maximum
cette case éviter des des possibles qu'à
valider cinq sur deux choses la c6
protège bien les quatre centrales foulée
trois quarts aile et j'ai six cavaliers
s'est replacé il se met du côté roy les
noirs sont bien bien masser côté roy on
peut pas dire qu'ils sont vraiment
menaçants puisque le blanc pas de
problème ils sont très bien aussi c'est
eux les blancs pourrait d'ailleurs
monter une attaque côté droit avec f4
plus tard mais voilà la masse de pièces
ici fait que savait difficile justement
monter une attaque notamment regarder
les noirs contrôle très bien qu'à z4 le
pion kg 6/4 ya trois éléments
ça fait beaucoup de monde quand même sur
cette case dans me2 voilà au mali
détournant les tours sont connectés
c'est toujours pratique on peut
coulisser on peut ramener la tour vers
le centre par exemple selon de choses à
5 menace bien sûr à 4 il faut bouger à
trois mêmes ont perturbé le camp blanc
on essaie de casser la structure où
placer un pion à 3 menaçant ici qui
contrôle gaza en b2 qui est un soutien
pour
une invasion ultérieure donc et blanc
laisse pas faire simplement à 4 voilà il
bloque aussi les blocs de là les pions
allèles dame tout en en prenant eux
aussi un peu d espace aux six échanges
mais donc le pion évident à 2 a disparu
et bien forcément on a il faut que les
blancs des se décide soit de reculer le
fou dans une position finalement assez
passive ici parce que ce soit aussi
c'est bien parce que si on joue ces deux
je pense qu à bessens qui possible b4
happy baie 3 ans ultra possible qui
protège attaquant le fou ces deux bons
donc les blancs ont choisi d'échanger
voilà c'est réglé et puis on prend
intéressant mais à double tranchant
alors c'est intéressant parce que on
ramène le pion vers le centre c'est un
premier point mais on a doublé des pions
quand même et aux autres points quand
même positif par ce point négatif ici on
a ouvert la colonne f
voilà on menace déjà d'en prendre
cavaliers donc là il a fallu que avant
de jouer ce coup franc aussi ce
qu'arsène à calculer et simplement il va
jouer
voilà cavaliers des deux n'a pas de
problème parce que sur cavaliers prend
un échec
il va jouer roi je crois j'ai deux et on
peut plus bouger le cavalier sinon la
dame est perdue donc lecavalier sera a
perdu e
donc c'est pas une bonne affaire il faut
pas faut pas jouer qu'à métro m2 c'est
un piège petit piège montrent qu'ils ont
que c'est une une impossibilité tactique
que carey qui ne voient immédiatement en
finançant même calculer des cinq lors
des 5
je pense coup un peu douteux parce que
carla qui n'a ici bon à la fois on se
dit c'est dynamique en compterons mais
après si on peut sur quatre mais on
laisse deux pions comme ça doublé là sur
une colonne et on voit qu'on va voir que
carsen va profiter de ça avec avec brio
voilà alors ça c'est difficile à juger
tout de suite c'est du long terme
mais voilà on comprend l'idée c'est que
ça affaiblit un peu comme s'affaiblit au
sein de tout simplement
et ça laisse deux pions doublé comme ça
on ne peut consister en arrière voilà
damage 5 up attaques ultérieures f3
invite qu'avaient les problèmes de roy
g2 lequel il peut plus bouger ensuite on
va revenir en deux il est perdu donc il
va falloir faire quelque chose et en
même temps un petit oeil sur scène ça
mange pas de pain la dame est bien placé
aux 5
elle n'est pas attaquable c'est une
position intéressante pour la dame voilà
le cas il y revient et la hache 4 et où
tu vas pas facile maintenant si on
pourrait revenir en jeu 7 on peut venir
pourquoi pas en effet cette envisageable
mais après il ya des cas les g4 faut
calculer
voilà dames après du couffo guangxi ont
fait cavaliers f7 par exemple je pense
que calais jk de gagner parce que on
peut regarder rapidement qu'avec cette
voie là hop calais g4 et ou à la dame
l'un d'eux déjà ne peut pas garder
cavaliers à c'est ça le problème d'un
médecin d'origine c'est pas possible
dames cette pouf le sapeur le cas légers
kg 6 juillet donc ça perd donc attention
kg 5 h 4 c'est pas celle de reculer en
chaussettes c'est possible on aurait pu
aller en chaussettes mais calais g4
reste pénible on est obligé de devenir
f7 s'est passé quand même pas super fort
et puis derrière il ya le pion aux
scènes qui emprise oui on regarde ici
kvh 7 kg 4 là on est obligé de reculer
et voilà on voit l'idée de que des cinq
ans là ça affaiblit c'est là pouf on
perd un pion et c'est alors là c'est
contre car sienne au championnat du
monde un pion central peut presque dire
là que c'est presque perdre la partie
enfin pas tout à fait où quand il ya du
match mais sur mes dur quoi h4 donc ici
les noirs de joux le seul coup qu'ils
restent calmes relief trois mois la kf3
mais il suffirait il suffit ceci dit
permet aux blogs en train finale et
carson ils adorent ça et final les super
technique en finale il très très forts
car les profs f3 dans prend la preuve
trois tours prend et maintenant ça et
roger 2 la tour est attaqué alors
l'erreur ça ce que ça fait l'erreur la
seule erreur c'est pas bon meneur en ont
ils auraient pu jouer tous réfutent
c'est possible c'est pas une erreur je
pensais à un coût mais ça marche pas tu
aurais fut donc je pensais à jouer
kalyev 5 quel excellent puisqu'on
perturbe ici on menace au roi prend tour
voilà une tour prend gagné qualité en
fait on peut prendre des 3 et ça m'a
donc ici dans cette position sans doute
tout simplement par contre le coût h5 et
pénible parce que le cavalier peut pas
venir en f4 ni henri iv est obligé de
repartir en arrière et les blancs petit
avantage des espaces on va pouvoir jouer
sans doute ensuite
tour d ajustement tour en d1 et en
menace car lipsynch et la tour va avoir
des problèmes
voilà les pats safe en f3 ça qu'il faut
comprendre ici le cavalier bouche par
exemple ici alors on joue ça pour
justement protéger des 3 et aux menaces
khalip 5 gagne la qualité c'est la tour
est froide et est prise au piège
donc voilà donc ceci étant dit et donc
comme on peut pas il vaut mieux
l'enlever tout de suite pour la cph et
inph 7 c'est bien ça protège la septième
rangée bon pour l'instant les bleus
peuvent rien faire soit 7e et c'est pas
plus mal ça ce n'est pas beaucoup
d'autres cases aussi en réussite on
aurait pu se faire attaquer par kg 4
mais surtout on prépare éventuellement
un doublement des troncs et non pas de
problème ici c'est bien protégé mais bon
ça mange pas de pain comme dit l'autre
t'aurais feu voilà carsen veut pas
laisser sa tour en effet il veut garder
son coeur en f2 il veut garder tous à
protéger en cas de doublement il veut
mettre la tour à eux deux voilà comme ça
il à la fois un oeil sur la deuxième
mais aussi la garde un oeil sur cette
colonne cette eau un peu plus un peu
plus d'air koala h55 ou intéressant des
noirs couach 5 ça et vite c'est évident
que les blancs jouent eux-mêmes h5 parce
que h55 allait quand même on l'a vu tout
à l'heure on vient de le voir il n'y a
pas de case niv 4 nièce cas des oubliés
de repartir dans son camp et sa patte
scène d'aller chercher ce pion ceci dit
ça affaiblit un peu le pion aussi car
beaucoup plus tard
par exemple si on arrivait avec le câble
y réussissent par exemple cavaliers
fuites sur h 5 kalyev 8 calé dès cette
4e 6 est il faut trouver un moyen de
protéger ça donc ça va ça s'est un peu
affaibli sens si on veut bon ceci dit
les noirs préfère en tout cas l'empêcher
avec h5 et bloquer sa les blancs replace
leur pièce cavaliers fin ils cherchent
la meilleure place de la castre son
cavalier il veut peut-être une était en
3 il peut plus vraiment bouger donc il
change il veut venir
par exemple la f3 si les noirs 2
le palais tour bref trois je peux venir
ensuite engagé 5 c'est intéressant
donc je peux passer par des deux f3 en
d2 je peux aussi venir en b3 et 3 c'est
pas mal j'attaque à 5
donc je force les noirs bouche a poussé
un pion donc ça fait bien un tout petit
peu bien gardé la tour en 1 8
voilà donc voilà donc ils veulent alors
qu'à retrouver faisait rien et en plus
je libère l'action de la tour sur le
colonnes voilà donc c'est bien sûr c'est
mieux de chercher la meilleure case pour
ses pièces et d'augmenter la puissance
de feu de toutes ces pièces trois fuites
donc les noirs se disent mon roi
finalement il n'est pas forcément bien
placés ici aussi je vais plutôt l'amener
vers le centre pourquoi pas quel est des
deux atouts ya plein de coups possibles
m plein plein de cas on en croit pas
toutes analysées sont toute la partie
longue vous allez voir recette
voilà les noirs c'est une magnifique
finale vous allez voir sa recette le roi
a toujours donc vient vers le centre
tours 2 voilà j'anticipe touré fuite qui
attaquent rêve deux des six et voilà ça
y est calée f3c l'heure on aime le dire
les noirs ont choisi de ne pas doubler
ils ont laissé faire cailler trois bons
il aurait pu l'empêcher aussi tout
retour et fuite et là ben voilà il
laisse faire kg 5 qui est une très bonne
case pour un cavalier il est défendu on
peut plus attaquées par un pion du
montgenèvre scène où son cas ce faible
bon et puis après par contre-attaqués
rien ce qu'on attaque 6 mais bon la tour
est bloqué par le pion aux 5
ceci dit on peut imaginer des attaques
ont doublé tour des 5 en cas de prise a
pris 0,6 et on pénètre en 6 avec un
échec pourrait même jouer des cinq
toutes deux des quatre tuiles d'ailleurs
des cas tout de suite en cas de prise
prise là en d5 et en cas de reprise
il y aurait tout aussi ces chèques
protégé par le cavalier avec gain du
carnegie 6 voyez donc c'est le problème
un de ses pions doublé là qui sont une
cible à tout moment les blancs peuvent
ouvrir ici tours 7
voilà donc élu noir résolve le problème
il contrôle tout la voix contre le 6
c'est très passif mais bon tu es solide
pas grand chose pour les blancs sont
quand même un tout petit peu mieux
maintenant quand même on va le dire il
faut regarder la structure d'options
quand même est propre
voilà où campion échanger et noir quand
même ça avant la colonelle sert à rien
on le voit venir il devrait faire
finalement et à tout moment les blancs
peuvent prendre un dessert poussée des
quatre un bon ils peuvent créer petit
menace et non poussant h5 certes ça
empêcher h5 des blancs mais ça a laissé
la case g5 pour le cavalier donc il est
un projet de lâcher de l'espace voilà
les blancs un petit avantage des espaces
rien de décisif mais bon c'est typique
c'est très bon pour le style de carsen
ça ils aiment bien ça un peu là
capablanca l'a fait jouer des finales de
ce type là avec la micro avantage est
qu'il arrive à transformer très patient
et la fois très précis donc il faut en
face à avoir les nerfs solides pour
tenir tout reste que huit ans plus
sachant que carsen doit absolument
marquer dans les deux parties qui reste
c'est presque l'idéal ya réussi vraiment
a obtenu une position idéale pour son
style de jeu 4 3 il revient on y voit
qu'ils devraient faire de plus il veut
il veut replacer ces pièces encore
quelles suites voyez tourne un peu
autour la voilà alors là ce coup là
c'est le coresponsable ça lâche un peu
au sec et les blancs profite avec boom
des quatre voies la d4 intéressant très
intéressant comme coup leur attention si
les noirs prennent d'abord en quatre il
y aurait pu on prend 1,5 et cheikh suivi
de tout reprendre 4 je gagne un pion et
oui s'il faut pas d'abord par l'échec et
du coup julien des pions donc les noirs
ont pas trop le choix puisque la menace
ici c'est bien sûr de prendre ici les
noirs protège avec le cavaly ça va pas
imaginer un cavalier vii
ça serait une faute très certainement on
peut faire pions prince aime tout
simplement c'est encore mieux comprendre
5calais prendre 5 est maintenant très
certainement qu'à les prendre c'est
droit prend et pourquoi on fait ça parce
qu'on met le roi devant découverte donc
ici on prend en d5 et les noirs sont
obligés de reprendre du roi et tout de
suite on a un tueur isolé sans compter
que bien sûr on à 1 tour 5 échecs qui
gagne h5 et à 5
mais même un terme structure même sans
regarder les pions qui ont gagné en plus
à la fin c'est ce moment
c'est un massacre c'est pas bon donc sur
des 4b il faut prendre là on est obligé
de prendre
donc voilà ça y est il qu arsène
transforment petit peu ça la pression
qu'il a monté dans quelque chose d'un
peu plus d'un peu plus solide on sent
qu'il revient dans le match il a moins
fatigué que les parties précédentes
l'aca cette fois sur l'échiquier tout
simplement sur la sur la position
voilà simplement de cavale et prend
voilà cavale et prend et ils ont des
problèmes on peut pas jouer 5 à cause de
cavaliers et f5 échec en cas de prise
que si les noirs prennent ensuite du
pion kalyev 5 fourchette
et si on prend de lothian mais le
cavalier de nouvelles cases forte en
bessin qu'avec un échec et on a toujours
les pions centraux qui sont faibles
aussi donc les noirs jouent un coup j'ai
six pour ans pour contrôler la case f5
voilà il empêche comme ça définitivement
un cavalier donc et f5 donc en cas de
prise en dessin qu'on reprend du point e
il n'y a pas d'échec en effet 5 pour
l'acidité de g6 d'avoir des contenus
quelle suite il est quand même
voilà là il fait pitié un art d'écrire
comme il est complètement hors jeu là
voyez des manoeuvres simple une finale
simple on prend de l'espace on profite
des petits pions doublé des noirs là
pour monter tranquillement
progressivement comme ça une pression
centrale sur ses pions et puis il crée
une rupture au bon moment il ya tout
fait dans les règles de l'art la
personne sur trois tranquillou un
presque au coude attendent ici c'est au
tour 3 presque alors c'est presque mais
ça l'est pas parce qu'évidemment l'idée
de des blancs c'est de venir à f3
pourquoi m6 encore une classe maintenant
qu'on a joué g6 c'est pour ça que l'on
dit souvent des convois un pion créé des
faiblesses c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pousser l'adversaire à pousser ses pions
on laisse des casses faible dans son
camp donc tout restera tous réussissent
tous les six attaques
si ce qui est cloué en cas de prison
peut pas reprendre du pillon attaque le
pourquoi pas le pion g6 qui fait que le
kayak 8 est obligé de rester là bref
donc les noirs justement le sort tout de
suite comme ça voilà moi n'y sera pas
bloqué et maintenant les blogs
choisissent de jouer aux 5
hossein échec ça fixe rade escaliers
magnifiques caves et des cats parce que
ils attaquent le 6 qui reste donc une
petite faiblesse même si c'est bien
défendu si les noirs le chasse par ces
cinq ils ont une superbe kazan b5 et me
donne un cachet si c'est super faible
avantage blanc devient net positionne
allemand saynètes mettant matériellement
ya rien mais voilà positionner le mans
il ya les noirs n'ont pas l'équivalent
ils ont pas d point de rentrer
maintenant se jouer précis parce que la
moindre imprécision et noir peuvent re
ensuite au sortir de l'eau et puis pour
gagner la partie il faut encore
transformer s'est transformé ça car ce n
est bien parti pour
pour égaliser dans ce match là voilà
tout cas on sent en ce moment là que
tout est dans ces mêmes pour pour le
faire trois des sept tomes f3 ont
regardé comme les pièces noires se
gênaient le cavalier empêche la tour de
bouger la haye les deux de la tour les
deux tours sont quand même très très peu
naudin ici à défendre tout et 3 avec le
roi avait trois pieds sur pied aussi ce
qui est qui et boiron qui bouche et en
plus maintenant qu'il est payante 5
devant ça sert à rien le défendre voilà
il est blanc aux mille et les noirs dans
l'embarras kvh 6 voilà ah bon les noirs
place leurs cavaliers ils veulent sans
doute venir en aide 5 comme ça ça bloque
le passage de la tour peuvent aussi plus
tard venu angers kabyle il sera chassé
ensuite facilement par istres on doit
aussi s'attaquer aux g6 dont les cèdent
pas de problème pas facile quand même
pour les blancs ont attaqué les pions
parce que là ça s'est défendu mes mains
en imaginant qu'on puisse tout aussi si
on arrive à mettre 400 cavaliers de
carrière quatre attaques à la fois j 6
et si on protège c'est aussi ce qui est
en crise donc ça serait une idée pour
les blancs mais s'ils ont le temps qu'on
fasse ça si on fait cavalier de tout de
suite cavale et j'ai quatre attaques la
tour et le pion et le cavalier bloc
maintenant la défense donc on peut pas
faire n'importe quoi donc les blogs
créés un nouveau front en l'on dit
souvent aux échecs donc ça retenir ici
que pour gagner il faut pas qu'ils aient
une seule faiblesse mais au moins deux
et si possible sur deux camps c'est
encore mieux donc là d'une faiblesse ici
c'est la case et 6 c'est la colonne f
qui est contrôlé par les blancs c'est
les pions aussi c'est g6 qui sont un peu
sous pression
un coin faible mais si les noirs sont
bloqués ici ils peuvent tenir avec les
pièces mans le problème c'est que si on
crée un deuxième front c'est ce que va
faire craint car celles ci ont créé un
deuxième front les doigts reprend pas la
voix défendant ce front là et se feront
la marne et ça c'est un modèle un des
quatre magnifiques apprend après la
superbe déjà allées noires peuvent plus
jouer ces cinq ses deux pions sont
menaçants ont peu joué à cinq qui
bloquera un tiers dans la chaîne de
pions qui laisse des possibilités comme
camel et trois cas laissé cinq échecs
avec pression sur six en plus maintenant
qu'on a pris la tour là à du jeu on peut
venir en c1 aussi faire pression
pourrait envisager après par exemple à 5
regarder la tour en c1 à 6 et si la base
saute qu'est ce que devient c6 abc
emprise et si une tour pénètre a lancé
morales aurait jusqu'à les d4 est
superbe
avantage blanc commence à devenir net
net net à karak insee fait quand même un
petit peu un petit peu manipulé là il
s'est fait il s'est fait faire des coups
de magie là il n'a pas compris ce qui
s'est passé voilà en quelques coups là
une dizaine de coups car ce n a réussi à
transformer une position très serré sans
échange de pions en quelque chose de
manifestement dominateur avec les pièces
qui ont du jeu beaucoup d espace pour
lui et les noirs complètement quand on
est en défense mais ça reste solide
les huit tours f3 magnifique position de
quart scène quel magicien dans cette
partie vraiment là c'est superbe tour f
3 ans la garde la colonne f à tout le
monde donc ça immobilise les pièces six
ans même si a pas de menace directe les
pièces doivent rester en place or ces
tours dès que
et puis les blancs on est moyen
d'améliorer leur position c'est autour
desquels bouche de l'autre côté créé des
menaces est là aussi on peut jouer à
saint pons jouer b5 en plus beaucoup de
choses cassis et les noirs attendent
voilà maintenant il mena ils vont venir
avec c'est ceci l'aidera à les blancs
reviennent plus je reviens g8 et je
répète et là je suis content avec bien
sûr avec les normes et la voilà à 5
il le fait à 5 voilà très bon coup je
contrôle a6b si ccsn donc j mobilise
entièrement cette cette chaîne que je
vais pouvoir attaquer une sorte d'
attaques de minorités j'ai deux pions
contre 3 là une sorte de la taille d'une
minorité c'est à dire une attaque
minorité c'est typiquement ça c'est
moins deux pions kathak plus de pions
mais qui laisse une semi colonnes sert
la colonne s'est on peut appuyer nos
deux pions en attaque avec une colonne
ouverte
on peut casser cette chaîne et voilà ça
serait ça serait la panique chez nombre
vraiment kalyev 5 voilà je leur
placement cavalli mais dont je bloque
cette colonne ça c'est une bonne affaire
là il nous a envoyé un aussi sur les
nombres sont pas non absents et non non
pas une absence de ressources ils ont
quand même des ressources et regardez
maintenant personne vivant né change pas
il pas fou si l'échangé belle et noir
simplement on pourrait sans doute
reprend dû plonger peut-être même du
pion
pour métro 1 6 avec une position
quasiment impensable
je ne sais pas en tout cas il choisit de
jouer calais b 3 qui est beaucoup mieux
puisque voilà on met l'accent sur le
fait que la casse et 5 au 6 échecs qui
ont mieux cavaliers qui attaquent deux
pions qui ne veut pas bouger
donc c'est quand même assez s'être la
des noirs anticipe m leroy tout de suite
on sait cette cavale et c5 pression sur
le pion sur le pion aux six la tour et 8
doit rester en défense
ab 8 ou les 3b 8 parce que les blancs
sans doute anticipe aussi que cette tour
protège la 7e donc ils mettent laurent b
voilà comme ça c'est tour protège aussi
la septième à parce qu en cas d'invasion
par l'allée ici une tournée sur la
colonne à si l'euro est un sessègnon et
on perdre du temps à défendre autour à
cet échec qui n'a tour pourrait prendre
le clavier d'abord moyens pour prendre
puis on prend tour à cet échec on prend
la tome on l'a maintenant on met 3 8
cette histoire là n'existe plus mais si
les types de partis d'opposition
on n'a pas besoin de calculer beaucoup
beaucoup non plus pour trouver des bons
coups parce qu'il n'y a pas de menace
directe cdd menace positionner avant
tout tomber un voile à ce magnifique
voilà c'est ce qu'on disait c'est que
les blancs beaucoup plus de menace à la
fois côté droit côté dames maintenant en
tourbe et un loterie db5 b5
puis on prend tout reprend et le pion
bessette est sous pression on peut jouer
à six derrière sagan le pion on peut
doubler les tours sur la colonne bcc
chaud pour les noirs là on a cette race
est super content car c'est n'a réussi à
obtenir cette position de pression là
donc la carac chine jouera à sète il
veut peut-être permettre un tour b8
ultérieure en tout cas ils empêchent à 6
ce qui pouvait être une autre idée aussi
à 6 maintenant bon ben c'est on va pas
prendre sans doute on jouera b6 façon
tour des 3 à leur tour des trois donc
les noms rangeront à cette tour des
trois c'est sans doute pour empêcher ce
cahier de bouger première points premier
point et
et aussi pour on peut jouer aussi f3
avec les blancs pour jouer
ultérieurement g4 ce qui peut être
intéressant pour chasser ce cavalier
ce cavalier f5 et mettre en mouvement
aussi nos pions ici parce que là on a là
encore deux côtés rois des pions mobile
alors que c'est plus difficile
d'envisager de pousser les pions pour
les noirs quoique ici j'ai 5e pouvait
être envisageable pour essayer de les
changer un maximum d'options sur la
colonne j'ai activé des pièces mais mais
mais regardez sont tellement sous
pression ici que même en ouvrant là
finalement il créerait plus des portes
d'entrée pour les blancs pour aller
gêner à l'euro 1 donc tour c'est cette
rencontre et passifs de défense mais bon
un coup solide aussi et non attendre
tour à 3 ces trois taux à 3 il est
tranquille car c'est ni menace tout
quand il veut là il joue en 3 1 alors on
peut toujours menacés baissait alors si
on joue à six il y aurait sans doute b6
et on ait envie de partir et j'ai pas
sur son très bon pour les volets blancs
parce que finalement ça va être très dur
de déloger le roi aura 7 qui bloque tout
et c'est presque les pieds noirs qui
risque se mettre en mouvement
dr à trois c'est peut-être on veut jouer
d'abord b5
je ne sais pas donc allée des quatre
voilà le problème est sûr c'est qu'on
enlève le la protection de la case des
cas cahier des quatre donc on va pouvoir
venir en baies -celles en tout cas on
empêche b5 aussi donc les noms et les
blancs laisse passer ce cavalier bon
tour des uns et la les blocs diesel
coûte maintenant tu choisis soit tu
viens b5 et je vais revenir sur le clown
f
soit tu reviens là et là maintenant je
vais peut-être jouer des scènes je vais
peut-être jouer à 6
je vais peut-être jouer car ya quatre
cas les v6 voilà je vais faire du jeu
elle dame mais tu choisis tu le laisses
pas là voilà donc les noirs reviennent
on va voir ce qu'ils vont faire les
blancs avaient pas tout de suite d'abord
orages trois là tranquille à tout moment
ils peuvent lancer des opérations là
mais pour que ce soit encore une fois on
l'a déjà dit maximum en termes de
potentiel d'attac
il faut créer deux faiblesses la
regarder les pièces blanches la tour une
menaçante lecavalier menaçant ce pion à
tout moment peuvent pousser soi b5 soit
à 6 on sait pas lequel il peut bouger en
1/4 venir en b6 bon bref il
ça joue cette tour peut choisir à tout
moment de passer à gauche ou à droite
et maintenant si on met en mouvement
cette note chaîne depuis on peut
craindre y ont passé presque s3g quatre
pions prends tu comprends et avec g4 h4
on a un qui ont passé on peut créer une
deuxième faiblesse ici obligeant les
noirs à contrôler deux deux côtés et là
ça devient dur en kayak 6 voilà donc 6
et la voilà ça y est f3 si on l'avait
dit à l'heure donc là par contre on
relance de venir sur la colonne f voilà
puisqu'on a bloqué la casse de
pénétration on peut encore envisager
quand même tour des quatre avec torres 4
mai et c'est pas dur pour les noirs de
mètres la tour f 7 et d'empêcher cette
équipe de la navy
voilà donc mais il faut quand même faire
attention tout reste à être tous les
codes quand même autour des 4 quand même
voilà ça veut dire bénin b si tu bouges
je viens là si tu bouges cette tour tu
perds aussi ce qu'est ce que tu fais ce
que si tu reviens à f/5 je peux venir en
d4 et je menace g4 et tu as des deux
gros gros gros soucis avec une majorité
de pions là qui commence à faire
pression la côte est roi est sous
pression car hakim la qualif scène quand
même élan il revient dès 2006 carsen
finalement il joue pas à tours 4
il a renoncé à cette idée il revient en
d2 et après ce que les noirs tour est
presque revenu à 6 pour dire à toi mais
n'ont joué beaucoup d'attentes aussi le
10 et le coup de voile à toi parce que
trois sets c'est pas un coin
oui bien que l'aérien sa menace rien du
tout je peux pas jouer g5
c'est peut-être si c'est contre roger
4-way ses comptes roger car si je joue
j'ai quatre effectivement puis on prend
qui on prend et je peux prendre ça
serait une catastrophe bien sûr je peux
prendre le cavalier voire même avec la
tour eiffel faut calculer mais ça a
l'air bon puisque l'euro est obligé de
descendre et on peut sortir ensuite le
cavaly sans problème oui c'est contre ce
coup ci contre au g4 d'accord tomber 3
tourné trois mêmes idées que tu à leur
attention et oui regardez la tour de
contrôle des quatre cavaliers peut pas y
aller comment on fait pour empêcher des
scènes mais on peut pas tous eu 7 alors
les noirs du coup peuvent pas empêcher
mais ils disent ben spies se surprotéger
doubler les tours sur la septième rangée
à la fois je garde un oeil sur 1,6 mais
aussi je contrôle bien voilà à côté du
roi au cas où
au cas où les blancs double les tours
avec un cavalier ici si j'ouvre ici il
n'y aura jamais de tomber cet échec avec
les deux tours si elle n'avait qu'une
j'aurais pu le faire pour des détroits
un petit coup là alors là moi je ce coup
là moi je sais pas trop expliquer aux
d3e garde un oeil à la fois sur trois et
sur des quatre avec le cavalier là mais
j'avais déjà je contrôlais déjà bon mais
ça laisse un taureau mobile je peux
bouger tout en empêchant de travailler
de devenir bon et jeudi au noir à toi
aussi que font les noirs mais parce que
si je sors d'ici je peux peut-être joué
g4 il ya plus on produit on prend ya
plus de tout reprendre
si je bouge cette tourbe et je laisse
jouer b500 contrôler la 7e je sais pas
tout rage suite pour les noix très bien
tomber un bon petit peu des coups alors
c'est la pendule peut-être qu'ils jouent
un peu aussi je sais pas voilà tout âge
7 aux attentes
il faut que les blancs fasse quelque
chose qui cherche car c'est ni à
chercher bon il a bougé un peu ses tours
bon maintenant c'est le moment faut
jouer mais c'est un coup bas il faut
dire que ça parce que je peux pas encore
jouer au g4 faudra que j'attende 7% à 1
où le cavalier pour envisager de jouer
g4 donc ici b5
on y va c'est parti donc on sent que là
le jeu s'ouvre ça va devenir chaud prise
tomber si ça te ra les pions et ses
terrasses et les noirs prennent donc
tout reprend et là je peux doubler les
tours le cavalier est dominée pour
l'instant voilà c'est pour ça que cette
tour est venu en d3 très certainement
jonathan les divulguer tout à l'heure
donc ça empêche le clavier de bouger ne
peut pas venir en aide et 6 non plus
donc il est que là il est que là il peut
pas être ailleurs
attention maintenant l'idée dé blanc le
sait devenir en b 6 pourquoi le moment
on protège 6 on est obligé de revenir en
défense
attention par contre maintenant qu'on a
joué bessengue lecavalier csn n'est plus
protégé par un pion aussi alors les
noirs jouent un très bon coup sans doute
peut-être le meilleur mais ils sont
quand même sous pression là c'est quand
même très dur maintenant un pour les
noirs on le voit on le sent bien si ce
qui est faible tomber si ce qui menace
bon et ça gagne un pion quasiment parce
qu' on se caille g7 ça fait appel à
jouer quand même surtout que les blancs
pourrait doubler les tours sur la
colonne b et ensuite jouer à 6 force à
amphion prend et tout reprend maths et
si on prend pas bien on va se prendre
une dame dont 17 8 tout simplement bien
matt simmons attaqué très fort il faut
faire quelque chose
c'est un bon coup là carrier qui n'y
fait des quatre fois la d4 c'est pas mal
c'est intéressant on va pouvoir en ahl
cazaux trois ans peuvent venir en 3 ça
peut être intéressant même si ça laisse
le pion des quatre ça empêche la tour
devenir en c3 mais ça ça laisse aussi le
pion isolé c'est comme un talent quand
je jouais des cat rie et tout seul ce
pion mais ce tour b6 voilà ça y est boom
attention ça a l'air fou tu ne vois pas
que l'ombre de sa donc maintenant les
noirs vont lâcher un pion et oui ils
vont lâcher ce pion qui joue sur
pion passer un petit peu aussi un des
quatre ils essaient d'avancer le pion
passé donc cette tour va devoir rester à
la défense et on joue un tour b 6 on est
obligé de laisser faire tour ses sept
c'est l'idée des noirs regardez le cas
ben ali va devoir bouger puisque il ya
plus de pions pour le protéger comme
tout à l'heure il va prendre mais sur le
pion 6 6 mais du coup la torah pouvoir
pénétrer en c3 où le coût des quatre
aussi contre le 3 mai contrôle aussi c3
et du coup on se crée une contre chance
voilà une meilleure façon de de jouer
c'est de créer des contre auchan calais
prend 2,6 pour ces 3 et regarder très
joli coup de carsen très jolie j'aime
beaucoup secoué les magnifiques c'est
superbe carrière quatre magnifiques
magnifique coup puisque en cas de prise
prise mais le cavalier est un bloqueur
ici magnifique et l'italie sont
excellent bloqueur c'est connu mais en
plus en jouant saab sas g600 prises à la
fois du cabinet de la tour attention le
pire des cas très menaçant la contre
chances des noirs n'est pas négligeable
du tout c'est passé loin d'être gagnée
au coran il foyers encore dû encore du
terrain tour c'est cette les noirs
choisissent de doubler menace tout
reprend câble et prend sans doute suivi
de tours c3 est le cas les bouchers f3
temps des 3 est libérée
et attention là contre chance et les
réelles donc foot les blancs jouent très
précis ici joli coup sans doute pas le
meilleur il y aurait pu prendre un car
c'est ni si angers 6 il aurait pu
prendre un g6 laisser laisser les blancs
en prendre en d3 car les prendre et a
pris sur tours c3 eh bien on aurait pu
jouer touré fils était intéressant pour
garder cette variante regarder sait
qu'arsène raté un truc ici parce qu'il
n'a pas joué ça
il aurait pu faire ici on regarde tout
reprend g6 salesse lecavalier en l'air
ici qu'il est plus protégé par un pion
saleh se purge cinq ans prise et si les
noirs continuent leurs plans il n'y a
pas trop de choix d'ailleurs maintenant
tour c3 est intéressant puisque si
lecavalier bout je prends f3 aura déjà
très fort et sidya touré fils et oui je
protège f3 en fait voilà que j'attaque
le caillage protégés seront si les noirs
prennent ici prises ratées on n'a que
des pions passé lié c'est pas grave le
pion patient pourra même se sacrifier à
la limite avec la tour de l'élection
passée liées là sont elles très souvent
même plus puissant qu'une tour mais de
toute façon je pourrais facilement
ramener la tour sur la colonne ici à d
et tous pousser mes pions ensuite
tranquillement et la majorité de pions
blancs et est tout à fait gagnante n ya
pas de problème donc ça a l'air très
très bon et sam était quasiment à faire
entre la partie cette variante la
houlette quoi car s'il joue un coup pas
mal mais bon un peu moins bon sans doute
calais des 5
c'est intéressant ça laisse la prise en
d3 pour prendre en ces sept et ça laisse
en toujours le plan de 600 prises mais
le pur f3 va être en prise aussi donc
derrière il ya purgé trois qu'attaquer
pas le cavalier donc kara qui n'en
profite tout reprend qu'elle prend et
maintenant attention quand même puisque
là et la menace pour les blancs les
blancs aussi c'est de faire cavalier
échec roi va sur la huitième tout projet
6 avec menaces ne mate et oui menaces de
maths est pas facile à paris donc voyant
cette menace car à qui ils anticipent
ils vous d'abord oib vite qu'elle est
simple quand même voilà du coup boom
boom attaque ici et voilà on s'est vite
ils préfèrent sortir le roi de la boîte
bon et joue bien il joue précis car akin
tombe pas dans le piège de faire
n'importe quoi
attention aussi parce que le calvez cinq
attaques des quatre là ça peut être un
thème aussi maintenant tout reprend g6
est au projet 6 protège g3 et ya pas de
glace de match puisque les lois ont fait
ce qu'il fallait ils sont sortis de la
boîte un voyez qu'ils en avaient
anticipé 1 et une boîte de mathelin et
anticiper car à qui il n'a pas laissé
faire pour preuve trois
et maintenant on sort du cloud âge avec
moi j'ai deux on attaque la tour on voit
la tour tomber trois têtes lecavalier
bon coup et voilà on est fille de
caraquet
car cette pardon choisi de jouer quelle
idée six semaines en échec
voilà ils rendent à la finale deux tours
et il rentre pas la finale au tour par
hasard s'il rendra finale deux tours
c'est que il a calculé que c'était
gagnante parce que sinon il n'aurait pas
fait ça il est quand même la 10e partie
d'un risque 2 et pour lui il estime
qu'au final de thorgal et on va voir ça
après calais prendre des six tours prend
des six déjà problème le pion des quatre
est attaqué ça laisse sa valse il est
blanc avec un pion passé ici sans doute
un deuxième ici puisque cela risque de
tomber et regarder la transformation car
ce n est magnifique tour 3 j'adore ici
donc il fait d'abord au cices a pas de
raison de donner le pion comme ça
ses sept tours prend il le laisse
prendra aussi ce qui laissera cette
rangée libre mais c'est pour ça qu'il a
joué 26 il serait mort prendre de
manière à laisser ce pion sans défense
et tour des cinq autres des cinq
superbes sans doute la meilleure ranger
pour la pour la tour se défend la fois 5
et j'attaque la faiblesse ici six
attendent c'est mort sert même si on
perd ça parce qu'on en a deux pions
passé lié donc la tourbe sacrifier
contre ça mais là à la tour quand elle
sacrifie contre-pied il reste un et on
peut pas empêcher depuis on va essayer
d'avancer en finale deux tours
cc c'est toujours gagnant voilà
c'est 99% deux fois ces gagnants c'est
quasiment impossible à défendre tours 6
on restera donc là car scène c'est en
fait quoi
mais qui va amener son roi et que ça
c'est mort voilà c'est ça qui l'a
calculé et donc c'est pour ça qu'il sait
que la finale est archi gagnant 1,8
bref 4 300 leroy venir en a six pour
attaquer ce pion mais regardez comme ce
pur 9 sont à la fin même en imaginant
qu'on perd de sa est très très loin de
faire dame alors que ceux là sont déjà
avancés un regard des rois j'ai cinq ans
la magnifique tour h 8 et là faut être
précis
attention roger 6 permet d'attaquer mais
ça permettrait tout échec tour prend
hélas le parti nul par contre oui oui
parce que là les pions passé vont
s'équilibrer
donc en fait là ils jouent très précis
carsen roi f6 superbe magnifique le plan
car ce n est très simple je vais jouer
toucher 5 ce qui empêchera jamais les
noirs d'attaqué trois profils tous les
seuils et ensuite je vais jouer orange
et 6 et cil à cil et noir essaie
d'empêcher par échec je jouerai g7 et
joe biden je ne partirai c'est la tour
qui prend et etc en plus garde le
contrôle de la 5
donc c'est mort voilà j'aurai deux pions
passé lié contre rien n'y a même pas de
plan précis pour les noirs magnifique
partie de carsen vois la magnifique
c'est très difficile de savoir où carey
qui n'a fait l'erreur il a cédé ses
découpes positionnèrent vous avez vu ce
le doublement des pions la sueur fou
prend 1,6 il semblerait qu'après
derrière il a eu du mal dès le début en
fait
alors si je retourne j'ai c'est de
retourner à ce fameux coup là faut aussi
cela qui semblait pourtant tout à fait
anodin
voilà ici là après à 4 ici en début de
partie
18e couffo 6 ça va vous prend il aurait
pu prendre de la dame alors peut-être ça
laisse ça laisse les blancs avec sans
doute de un peu l'espace bon très bien
et moi jaffe bipa mettions air en faudra
aussi bizarrement on avait l'impression
que ça lui donner un peu de jeu sur la
colonie fait tu sais mais les prix ont
doublé
on a vu lui empêché d'avoir lu empêcher
finalement d'avoir de la mobilité et ont
pu permettre à kars yen qui a joué comme
un magicien très difficile d'expliquer
tous les coups de pouvoir pénétrer sur
lui-même sur la colonne fo on l'a vu
tout à l'heure
créer des menaces à la fois côté droit
côté dames et ces moyens joué
magnifiquement alors qu'arras qui
n'auraient pu peut-être tenir mais il
s'est fait il ya ici fait car ces cars
sinisé voilà il est carbonisé cardiaque
initie et donc coup de tonnerre bis
cette fois car scène revient et il était
temps pour lui parce que ça a commencé à
avoir peur pour lui il semblait très
fatigué tout mais non non il avait l'air
super en forme ici
il a joué magnifiquement su très grande
partie et ses kayaks in qui doit être en
difficulté et moral maintenant puisque
il est presque le titre en main là
il traque il croque dans la seule partie
où il fallait pas craquer dès que carson
a eu de nouveau les blancs et bien il a
inversé la tendance voilà donc peut-être
que peut-être que ce coup de retour là
peu démoralisés cardiaque in il reste
deux parties et sinon on aura droit add
partage en partie rapide voilà merci de
m'avoir suivi un pour ce championnat du
monde 2016 sur canal tv
cette dixième partie entre magnus carsen
et sergueï kaliakine superbe magnifique
démonstration de carson une partie
modèle à étudier pour les pour les
finales pour les thèmes dans les finales
je pense que voilà c'est une partie qui
doit rester dans les annales et qui
rejoint très certainement les plus
belles finales de capable en cas c'est
un peu lié le style qui ressort de ce
fameux quart scène un peu nouveau
capable en quelque sorte voilà à bientôt
pour la prochaine partie la 11e sur des
gones halte et les mercinois ont suivi